some urban problems like sky-high
housing prices are mostly a curse in
wealthy cities other urban scourges like
filthy water and contagious disease
primarily impact the world's poorest
metropolitan areas but traffic
congestion is universal it is a
challenge in London and in Daraa Salaam
anytime there are a lot of people using
a small amount of space which is to say
anytime you have a city mobility is
going to be a challenge the ubiquitous
problem of urban immobility may be a bit
surprising after all urban densities
ultimate benefit is to make it easier
for people to physically connect with
one another yet that is exactly why
congestion is so important it strikes at
the most important function of urban
density you shouldn't expect this course
to help you negotiate your morning
commute any easier given the current
state of transportation in your city I
think you've got that one covered we're
going to focus on strategies to make the
city as a whole more mobile and that
could only help improve your morning
commute if you help in the fight to
improve transportation planning for your
city driving remains the norm in
American cities and so we're going to
talk about building more roads and
implementing other policies like
congestion pricing that make existing
roads more functional we're also going
to focus on the glories of the
underappreciated bus which can provide
cheap and flexible transportation that
is particularly well-suited for poor
medium density areas naturally we'll
also say something about trains as well
metro systems often seem to provide an
endoskeleton for global cities we want
to ask which investments make the most
sense and how to get the most out of
those investments we're going to talk a
bit about what often goes wrong in
transportation spending including high
costs and corruption and how to reduce
those costs mobility is particularly
tough for the world's poorest urbanites
who in cities like San Paolo sometimes
spend over three hours a day stuck in
traffic so better transportation isn't
just about saving you or me a few
minutes each day but it is also about
ensuring that cities provide access to
jobs for the most vulnerable urbanites
you